aura fallu sept semaines de tractations
et une ultime séance de négociation
marathon dans la nuit de mercredi à
jeudi pour parvenir à un compromis
le lendemain vendredi la cfdt et fo et
l'unsa ont annoncé qu'elle signerait le
protocole d'accord sur la revalorisation
des personnels hospitaliers hors
médecins ces ratifications permettront
de franchir 50% de représentativité
syndicale nécessaires à l'application du
texte
cet accord est un compromis acceptable
reconnaissant l'engagement sans faille
des agents hospitaliers et des ehpad
pendant la crise sanitaire et pendant
plusieurs années où ils étaient les
oubliés de la république
néanmoins ce protocole de revalorisation
n'est qu'une étape et ne saurait être le
solde de tout compte
un syndicaliste vous dira toujours qu'il
aurait voulu plus mais ça fait 2000 196
euros de plus par an quand on est
syndicaliste et qu'on s'est battu comme
notre fédération s'est battu on s'engage
là dessus parce que cet accord est un
gain salarial c'est la revalorisation
des grilles le protocole d'accord
négocié dans le cadre du ségur de la
santé prévoit une augmentation générale
des salaires de 183 euros mensuels pour
moitié en septembre puis en mars 2021
pas suffisant juge notamment la cgt et
sud santé qui refusent de donner leur
aval elle estime dans un communiqué que
le gouvernement méprisent leurs demandes
et leurs revendications notamment sur la
question des recrutements dans ce fameux
protocole est inclus 15 mille embauches
pour l'hôpital soit à peine 5 % des 300
mille postes manquants dans le spitalier
et les ehpad du public comme du privé
sans tenir compte de tous les postes
manquants dans le médico-social et le
social ces quinze mille embauches ne
sont qu'une goutte d'eau qui ne suffira
pas en remplacement des professionnels
en arrêt maladie à cause des conditions
de travail lamentables au remplacement
des professionnels qui ont accumulé des
centaines de journées de repos non
consommés et ne suffiront pas non plus
pour répondre aux besoins de la
population
six organisations syndicales dont la cgt
et sud santé appellent à une journée
d'action nationale le 14 juillet le même
jour le gouvernement prévoit de rendre
hommage aux soignants civile
militaires lors du traditionnel défilé
qui revêt cette année un format inédit